being balanced is usually the best way
to handle things right it's usually the
best way to handle things for some
reason human beings have a tendency to
not do that for some reason human beings
have a tendency to pick a direction and
go one thousand percent in that
direction in fact I had a name for this
when I was in the SEAL Teams and I was
putting guys through some training and I
would give them an adjustment I'd be
like hey you need to do a little bit
more of this guess what they would do
nine million percent in that direction
and I would call it or I'd say hey you
need to be a little less aggressive or a
little more aggressive and then I and
then they would do another iteration and
they would go so hard the opposite way
and say hey you guys just did this is
the term I'd say classic team guy over
correction meaning you say hey be you
know you got to be a little more
aggressive they go out there and just
get nuts or you say hey you need to
check yourself then they don't move